[Music]
foreign
hello there you are watching The Press
previewer first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive so uh let's
see what's on some of those front pages
for you now let's start with the
guardian which covers the home
secretary's resignation with the
headline bravaman's bombshell put truss
on the brink
the financial times describes the prime
minister's team as having been plunged
into chaos by today's events
the eye puts it bluntly chaos at the
heart of UK government
as well as 90-minute shouting match with
Liz is the headline for the Daily Mail
the Metro attempts a pun
so well over mess
I don't think I read that correctly Sue
Oliver that's it continuing its
comparison of Liz trust to a head of
lettuce the star says she's been cut to
shreds
and broken reads the front of the Sun
[Music]
reminder that by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
and we are joined tonight by Andrew
Pierce and Rachel cunliff welcome to you
both I hope you can gather your thoughts
uh amidst the the noise you know the
lunatics have taken over that side like
apparently but they've also taken over
the gates of Downing Street to keep this
well that's that's what he's been
playing an awful lot fun boy three yeah
the lunatics have taken over the Asylum
Let's uh delve into the papers now Sean
we will start with the the eye and uh
their headline at the chaos that has
ensued today what what has happened
today to lose a Home Secretary just a
few days after sacking your chance or
your chancellor who has pushed through a
budget a mini budget which had all the
marks of the hope the prime minister's
uh leadership on it all the things she'd
campaigned for during the leadership
contest but today the Home Secretary
sacked or resigned I'd say she was
sacked so there was a technical breach
uh when she put sent letters to
colleagues through her private email
address rather than an official
government email address is that really
a sackable offense maybe it's got Echoes
of Hillary Clinton which he was
Secretary of State but we know that
there's been an ongoing feud between the
Home Secretary and the Prime Minister
over immigration uh the the Prime
Minister wants to relax immigration
rules the Home Secretary absolutely does
not and that's what this has all been
about and and uh I think the Primacy has
been gunning for the Home Secretary for
some days and she got it today but the
result is absolute chaos and she's lost
a second senior cabinet minister in five
days it does not look good and uh people
are now saying the prime minister's got
days we'll speak a bit more about uh the
reasons for Stella Bradman leaving a
little bit later but to bring you in
Rachel you're you're uh real sort of
what do you think about what has
happened today
is gone and that's not even really the
main story uh the the the main story is
this utterly chaotic vote in in the
Commons over fracking where it's very
unclear still I think at the time that
we're recording whether it was a
confidence vote or or not uh the
government won it but there seemed to
have been quite a lot of disruption
perhaps to put it mildly I think it's
not clear whether the chief Whip and the
deputy chief whip resigned or have
unresigned or perhaps never resigned at
all that they were going to resign and
then didn't and don't and don't seem to
have done so but a very sort of strange
end to a debate in which conservative
MPS who are very skeptical of fracking
because of the views of their
constituents were pressured into
speaking in in favor of it in this
debate told it was a three-line whip
told it was a confidence issue and then
right at the end of the debate told
actually it wasn't
absolute absolute chaos and it kind of
makes the the Home Secretary resigning
which I think happened about 4 P.M this
afternoon it feels like old news now
doesn't it and the things if it's a
confidence issue if they make it a
confidence vote and Tori MPS don't vote
with the government then they have to
have the whip withdrawn then that causes
even more Chaos on the back benches
problems for the Prime Minister who
needs as much support as she can get she
doesn't need to be alienating MPS by
taking the whip away and some of the
people who didn't support the vote
tonight included people like Tracy
Crouch a really popular MP she was a
former Sports Minister and I think also
her net zeros are whoever that is why do
we need a Net series there was much
confusion about whether it was a company
I think we now think it wasn't but we
thought initially it was because that's
what we were told there was a text that
went round to MP saying absolutely is
three-line whip yes and and now it seems
not let's have a look at the guardian
and speaking a bit more about Zoella
bravaman's resignation describing it as
a bombshell and Andrew you've got some
more detail about that well
she um she was out on a raid this
morning with the police uh it was a to
do with people trafficking and she was
very confident she's very happy that it
all gone very well uh and she in the car
going back to London she's pretty tired
she sends uh these this correspondence
to a colleague which should have gone
through an official government email but
she sent it to a private email according
to the cabinet secretary Simon case
that's a breach of the rules Liz truss
said she had to go so let's trust
effectively sacked her but the real
story is this ongoing feud between the
two women over the issue of immigration
a key part of it of of the battle the
Home Secretary wants to take a really
hard line on it she wants to post brexit
control our borders but that prime
minister was siding with the treasury
and other parts of the white ore machine
to say let's relax the rules and get
more people in the Tory Manifesto says
very clearly we are going to stop low
level immigration coming into Britain
and and according to brabhaman trust was
not sticking to the management was a
massive brow which is referenced in your
paper at our front page tonight we've
got it exclusively that there was a
90-minute shouting match between the
Home Secretary and the Prime Minister
last night doesn't take much to work out
that then a few hours later when the
Home Secretary resigns
she was elbow dabbed so and she's going
to just sorry to say and she's going to
make a resignation statement tomorrow
and she will not pull her punches
because she never does and that's going
to Heap the pressure on the Prime
Minister because the resignation letter
they're normally diplomatic Affairs
right oh boring she absolutely put the
boot in on the prime minister so Rachel
Andrew they're saying it actually was a
sacking well I think it was a conflict
of interest shall we say that I think
actually rather than looking at the
state of this government might be quite
pleased to be out of it certainly her
views on immigration have been at odds
with Liz trust is actually their entire
career has been a sort of free market
get the best people in quite relaxed
about the issue of immigration the Home
Secretary obviously the opposite but I
think it was also the appointment of
Jeremy Hunter's Chancellor that has
really sort of pushed this to a head
because one of the quickest things that
you could do to Spur growth in this
country is relax immigration rules and
get more workers in and help get GDP up
that way which obviously comes with a
whole lot of political issues but it the
sense is that that was the direction
that hunt was was moving in and was
moving the prime minister in and
actually in her resignation letter the
former Home Secretary mentions that she
was very concerned about the direction
the government was taking on immigration
also on other promises that had been
made in a change in direction that we've
seen since quasi-quarting was sacked
it's incredibly passive aggressive I
mean she talks about a
technicality she sent it to a trusted
friend she told somebody immediately she
reported it to the official channels
nonetheless she writes I made a mistake
I take responsibility I resign it's not
difficult to work out what that's a
coded message about she also remember at
the Tory conference she said that the
Prime Minister was was subject was part
of a coup it was a coup against the
Prime Minister after they ditched the
top rate of tax she's been telling
people in the last two days that the
appointment of Jeremy Hunt a remainer
who came last in the toy leadership
contest proved her point there was a
coup and she'd be even more adamant now
because she's been replaced by Grant
chaps of all people Grant chaps he
wasn't very successful as transport
secretary was he another Arch remainer
on the center left of the party who
backed Rishi sunak so two of the great
officers of state now three of you
include truss who voted for remain are
occupied by remainers that wasn't what
trust was promising in her leadership
campaign yes appealing to a broader base
now is that let's have a look at the Ft
they're talking about being plunged into
to chaos but uh Rachel the chaos has
been around for very many days it's not
just today well it's quite interesting
sort of on Monday all the talk was would
you be able to last the the day after
her Chancellor basically ripped up the
entire platform that she'd won the
leadership election on and then there
was the the Urgent question in the
Commons which she didn't turn up before
she let Penny Morton do it and then she
sort of turned up belatedly and blinked
at the camera and people were asking
genuinely is this woman okay and then uh
yesterday Tuesday it is Tuesday it's
difficult to keep track things seem to
stabilize a little bit everyone was
saying oh it's all resting on pmqs will
she turn up the pmqs on Wednesday well
she did she turned up she wasn't sick
she didn't run away she gave answers
which after the last couple of days is
kind of where the bar is and people were
going all right a couple of weeks until
the the Halloween fiscal statement the
Chancellor's gonna give maybe until
Christmas you know it's stabilized a
little bit then the Home Secretary goes
then we have this this own goal from the
government on this fracking boat whether
it was a confidence motion or or not
frankly the only question now is is when
and how quickly they can line up a
replacement for her and what about these
um allegations of bullying in the the
lobby today yeah now Chris Bryant labor
MP said he saw um MPS physically being
pushed into the lobby to vote with the
government
um I have to say I'm not shot by this
this is the sort of thing that's
happened before but in this febrile
atmosphere it's it's a sign of how
desperate they were that they were
worried that perhaps the vote would be
not as supportive as to us and they
wanted it to look as supportive as it
could and in the end it was a very big
victory for them and they didn't need to
be dragging people into the division
lobbies but
um but it's not the first time actually
and I've got to tell you it's happened
on the labor side too over the years
I mean very dramatic I'm not sure about
the pushing certainly lots of shouting
but I think what is true is that there
was a lot of outrage from conservative
MPS that they were forced into a
position of Defending something that
they don't agree with that their
constituents don't agree with because
they were told it was a three-line whip
support the Prime Minister and then that
U-turn basically humiliated them you've
had some very strong comments from
various backbenchers who don't normally
make those kinds of of comments and you
know earlier on in the day you had
William ragg saying that he wasn't sure
what to do because he wanted to vote
against the government but if he did
that he might lose the Whip and then his
letter against the Prime Minister
wouldn't count so it's kind of a game of
four-dimensional chess how do you get
rid of this prime minister very quickly
just time to have a look at the star and
they're continuing the unflattering
lettuce comparison but we were saying
previously that lettuce normally lasts
about seven days
um she's outlived the lettuce it has to
be said so I know the Stars today saying
the letters have been cut to shreds but
I think the letters is going to live on
for a few more days uh certainly perhaps
into early next week but you know this
terrible thing about this letters this
is being repeated all over across the
United States and front pages I mean the
British prime minister is becoming a
laughing stop which is not good for us
or for the country if you watch the
lettuce cam right now it's wearing an
eye mask they're playing relaxing sleep
music but earlier on in the day the
letters was posed next to a glass of red
wine and some tofu a comment about the
Home Secretary saying that it was it was
tofu eaters who were to blame for the
coup so that's the political comment and
the wokarati I think she she mentioned
karate I'm with her on that well we
won't get into that now we're going to
take a break Andrew Rachel thank you
very much for the moment coming up
does Netflix's the crown need a warning
to say it's fiction Dame Judy Dench I
think so we'll discuss that and more
next
[Music]
welcome back to Downing Street you're
watching the Press preview
well still with me Andrew Pierce and
Rachel come live to take us through the
papers that we've just got time to talk
about the crown and Judy Dench has uh
weighed into the argument now saying
that it should be broadcast as fiction
because so many people watch it and
think it is fact that's what happened
and it's a travesty really I mean I've
stopped watching the crowd because I
know it's fiction and I know it's all
about getting ratings and we're talking
about it's giving it more publicity but
it's so irritating the way they've taken
liberties with the facts and the latest
is suggesting that John Major when he
was prime minister Prince Charles tried
to persuade him to get the queen to
abdicate back in the 1990s not true that
there was an affair with Prince Philip
we've only just buried the Queen the
timing is terrible what do you think I
just heard from that the thought of John
Major having an affair with Prince
Philip which I'm not quite sure is is
but but I think I I think when the crown
started we were talking about the the
50s and it felt like history and it was
scenes that people recognized from
photographs uh some people obviously
would have remembered them that it was a
period that felt far enough away that it
could have this sort of documentary
history kind of feel to it now we're
talking about events in not in living
memory in very recent memory getting
closer and closer and closer and that
distinction between what fiction what's
dramatized what's sensationalized
probably does need to be made partly
because they put so much effort into
making it look real and look very
genuine and they've got the right
costumes and they've got their the
settings and and the the backdrops and
the hairstyles and all of that it does
look very real and I think perhaps a
warning saying this is fiction based
perhaps on real events probably is the
right thing to do just because it's so
recent yeah coming from something like
James Judy Dench who's a National
Treasure and an Oscar winner one of the
greatest actors in the world I think
that's quite significant you know they
are recreating the death of Princess
Diana in that Paris under bus for
dramatic effect how cheap is that I mean
really they really need to do that I
mean Harry and William if it's their mum
and it was a very distressing for
millions of people as well yeah I think
I think it's appalling Rachel do you
think it should have stopped as you say
when it started it seemed to be
recounting history do you think it
should have stopped at a certain point I
kind of bringing it bang up to date I
kind of think it's a victim of its own
success I'm not sure when it started if
they intended to take it all the way up
to what the present day the death of the
queen I'm not sure what the Natural end
point would have been but obviously the
first series was such a sensation and
now there's this expectation that it
will continue but there comes a point
where you're making sort of fiction
about real life and I sort of felt
something a bit similar watching this
England which is the the drama about the
covet early months of the covert
pandemic hyper realistic really really
good but also a kind of fictionalized
version of a period of history history
that we all just quite recently lived
through